I loved it right from the start
obviously all of James Wan's work has
helped pave the way for a movie like
Megan to exist the marriage of him and
one house is such a natural one Blum
House have just made some of the
greatest horror movies in the last 20
20 and James won likewise just the
Undisputed Master of the genre
especially when it comes to unsettling
goals I get accused of being the master
of killer doll movies
in those doll films my dolls don't
actually get up and kill anyone they
usually just vessels for uh demonic
entities and so I said well if people
are going to think of me as a killer
doll filmmaker let's actually do one and
hence the concept of Megan was born
James really wanted Megan to be her own
her own person
that he's in a better place now
no